good are you doing excellent it's always
a pleasure to see the two of you so I
want to start with David the thing I've
found fascinating about David is so many
filmmakers will just film with one
camera like Ridley Scott or the way
Roger Deakins like to work but David
will shoot these 15-minute takes with
four or five cameras you don't even know
where the cameras are sometimes can you
sort of talk about as an actor working
with someone like that and maybe how
that changes the energy on set I mean it
takes some getting used to at first I
mean the idea that you didn't know where
the camera was is so it goes against
everything you've kind of experienced
and learn as an actor because you always
know kind of where your light or your
camera is and then which is kind of
great because he stripped you away of
all of those little safety kind of
mechanisms that you might have picked up
you know so it felt pretty raw and
authentic and that's kind of what
McKenzie does he creates a habitat which
is kind of it's just real and and then
lets you go you know wild pack of
animals and it's only about halfway
through you've noticed that the that's
been on me the whole time and you know
and you know but there was documentary
filmmaking in a way you know it's what
story no I mean I would say yeah it's
incredibly frustrating at first it's
still kind of frustrating because I
think as an actor you have no can you
have even less control because you don't
know grayza cameras or what angle he's
on or is he close right
but I think that unstructured Ness and
that taking the rug out from underneath
you and not playing with the mechanisms
of standard filmmaking it's is exactly
what he's doing with hugh matically too
it's he hears we have a structure of a
film that one thinks should be
Braveheart or should go by certain
Hollywood tropes and hit certain things
and yet David flips it all on its head
scrambles it and puts it back in the
same structure for you to have
go hunting for meaning and figuring out
who these people are and that made it
interesting to me one of the things
David is looking for all that decision
he's looking for being truthful in the
moment but you're also portraying you're
trying to make it as authentic as you as
you can to the historical time period
that this is taking place so talk a
little bit about maybe like the research
like balancing that inner thought versus
like trying to be honest in that moment
if if that makes any sense yeah I think
you know you can only sort of read
between the lines and there's whatever I
think you say it quite beautifully is
like you know the movements by well this
this event happened and then six months
later this event happened right and then
so you're trying to try to humanize
these characters and find well where's
you know where it was the empathy live
between that and then how do you how do
you give them just a you know how do you
justify them and what have you pick -
yeah the character the more that I
investigate them became more nebulous
and more opaque the more that I knew the
dates and the facts and the combat
movements and the William Wallace at
least cinematically amperes so
monochromatic to me he's the reluctant
hero that needs to avenge the death of
his wife and then he goes on the moral
quest only to die very young you know
Bruce is a man that has loyalties
perhaps that are tied to the English
crown probably because he grew up with
these people he knows
King Edward from when he was a boy he
grew up with Prince the Prince of Wales
in London he rolled in a group of people
great wealth so these were people that
for all intensive purposes were friends
friendly at least so they're incredible
amounts of tendons and ligaments tying
these people together clans families
cousins all sorts of things and yet he
makes a decision to go against all of
that and the five hundred people fight
the strongest army in the world why he
did that was he power-hungry did he had
a selfless desire to
free his country I don't know but I like
the the complexity of it on that note I
already have to stop
I will just say congrats on the movie
and I enjoyed the newer cut
I think the newer cuts really good wait
you